donald trump s'impatiente la crise
sanitaire mondiale a mis un sérieux coup
de frein à la campagne présidentielle
américaine
une situation qui n'arrange pas le
président sortant très critiquée sur sa
gestion de crise le milliardaire
souhaite par tous les moyens de donner
un nouveau souffle à sa campagne
électorale
après la publication de sondages
défavorables plaçant son adversaire joe
biden en tête
trump a réagi sur twitter jetant le
discrédit sur le camp démocrate
nous ne pouvons pas laisser les fausses
informations et leurs partenaires la
gauche radicale les démocrates
d'inefficace s'en tirer en volant
l'élection ils ont essayé cela en 2016
qu'est ce que ça a donné le locataire de
la maison blanche n'hésite pas à s'en
prendre à la chine affirmant que l'
empire du milieu ne souhaite pas sa
réélection
la chine ne veut pas me voir réélu parce
que nous recevons des milliards et des
milliards de dollars plusieurs milliards
de dollars par mois de la chine
la chine n'a jamais rien donné à notre
pays la chine ne nous a rien donné pas
même dix centimes
ils ont indiqué notre pays pendant huit
ans et en toute justice pour by données
obama cela a commencé il ya longtemps
bien avant qu'il n'entre en fonction de
son côté pékin assure ne pas vouloir
interférer dans les élections
américaines
l'élection présidentielle américaine est
une affaire interne
nous n'avons aucun intérêt à nous
immiscer dedans en attendant nous
espérons que la politique interne des
états unis n'implique pas la chine des
déclarations qui interviennent sur fond
de tensions entre les deux pays
donald trump qui menacent pékin de
réhausser les taxes douanières a une
nouvelle fois remis en question les
autorités chinoises concernant l'origine
exacte du virus
le pentagone a par ailleurs annoncé
d'importants investissements pour
produire des masques en grand nombre et
ainsi ne plus dépendre de la chine sur
cette question